you could watch all of my YouTube videos
about property but if you skip this one
you could literally end up getting huge
fines go into court and potentially
facing time in prison because I'm going
to be talking in this video about
compliance I talk a lot about deal
selling rent to rent joint ventures
lease option agreements do you have any
idea how regulated these are becoming
right now because if you rent a property
then rent it out for a higher amount do
you realize you need the right contracts
you need Ico you need insurances the
consequences of not having are huge
because the government are making
examples out of people and you could be
that person you could go and package a
deal and sell it yeah I've just made
three thousand pounds because I watched
Samuel Lee's video but then you end up
in prison because you missed part of the
compliance it's very long-winded it
costs thousands of pounds to become
compliant it's extremely laborious and
can take many many months before you can
start trading legally so I'm gonna go
through the whole process and then I'm
going to show you a new revolutionary
hack that's going to make things a whole
so lot easier this is going to change
the game for property entrepreneurs and
investors in the UK but right now let's
say you're thinking about deal sourcing
let's say you're thinking about
packaging a deal and selling it we're
thinking about renting a property and
then renting out for a higher amount
what are the current process compliant
checks you need to be aware of well
let's go to Google and let's find out
top one is how to become compliant as a
deal sourcer the legal blog let's see
what it has to say so the first thing
what we've got here is anti-money
laundering a failure to register or
re-register a relevant business will
result in a penalty so how do we set up
anti-money laundering anti-money what
you exam it's an hours an hour and eight
minutes long video setting up anti-money
laundering costs hundreds of pounds and
it can take months you have to do an
exam it's a really laborious expensive
thing that's going to set you back
hundreds of pounds and that's just thing
number one that's just the first thing
let's see what else there is on the
article number two professional
Indemnity insurance sources should
ensure they have the necessary insurance
policies in place to ensure they're
covered if they make a mistake that
causes client Financial or reputational
loss property Indemnity prices start at
around 320 pounds so starting price is
320 pounds so now we're pushing about a
thousand pounds and again it's going to
take time to set that up too all right
next Ico registration how do you do that
well let's Google it here it is register
is there a fee yes there is of course
there's a fee so you're paying more and
more money more and more time we still
haven't managed to sell a deal yet so
all right next let's see what else you
need to do
Ombudsman membership membership to one
of the property Ombudsman is also key
sources can join the TPO or the PRS for
a membership fee which will demonstrate
their community's Professional Standards
so the PRS what's this the PRS is all
property agents are professionals that
carry out a state agent let in property
management work in the property industry
have a legal responsibility to join the
PRS what happens if I do not join the
property reader scam uh it could be
fined up to five thousand pounds and
ultimately closed down that does not
sound very good okay is there anything
else that we need to do contra tracks
okay property sources also commonly used
contracts with clients how much is it
going to cost to get contracts well
let's find out solicit fees for drawing
up deal packaging contract for these
types of contracts a thousand to five
thousand two fifty to one thousand five
hundred so we vary from solicit to
solicitor give you an idea we spent
about two and a half thousand pounds
including vat for our deal selling
contracts which we update every year so
okay so all in all with your property
Ombudsman or your redress scheme your
contracts your Ico your professional
Indemnity your anti-money laundering
checks just to become a compliant deal
sourcer you're probably talking
somewhere in the region of two to three
thousand pounds including contracts now
that's not a huge amount of money it's
fine you'll make that back on your first
deal the biggest problem that I am
facing with my students is the time
element the amount of time it takes to
get anti-money laundering I spoke to one
guy recently who said the whole process
took him eight months but then he wanted
to do rent to rent but then
huge problem if you wanna do rent to
rent that's a separate company and guess
what you need to go through a whole new
process of becoming compliant with rent
to rents and what's the process well
let's find out Stay With Me by the way
don't just think right now I'll forget
this I'm not going to even bother stay
with me because there is a revolution
happening okay step one company set up
great so you can set up a company that
might cost you a few hundred pounds if
you get an accountant to do it or you
can do it yourself on companies Made
Simple companies set up great next
Insurance public liability insurance as
well as professional Indemnity insurance
okay so there's two lots of insurances
sending us back hundreds of pounds on
our rent to rent business alone property
redress scheme you've got to get that
again if you sell a deal and the
investor is upset and they want to
complain and you can't seem to get a
resolution they will report you to the
property redress scheme the property
redress scheme will then investigate the
situation or mediate and ultimately will
basically say who's in the right who's
in the wrong so it gives you a sense of
covering and protection which is a
really good thing however they will
charge you for the privilege so you pay
your membership fee but then if you get
a complaint you'll have to pay to have
that investigated so again more costs
being swallowed up non-compliance and
serious and can result in significant
fines criminal prosecution and your
business being closed down so if you're
getting started and you're wanting to do
deal sourcing you want to get some rent
to rent this is a huge procedure and
pretty expensive one too there's three
massive problems for you if you're
wanting to get into property and do deal
sourcing rent to rent I mean the first
one clearly demonstrated from just
looking on Google is the amount of not
just money but also time needed to
actually set up and become compliant not
only is it going to cost you thousands
of pounds if you think about getting
your rent to rent compliance you do your
sourcing compliance your deal sourcing
contracts your rent to rent contracts
you're talking the best part of about
four thousand pounds but worse than that
is having to wait months and months and
months potentially to get everything and
get your ducks in a row before you can
start legally Trading and if you do
start trading too early then you could
potentially be fined and prosecuted so
that's the first obvious problem the
second problem is the overwhelming
amount of information around what you
need to do there's so many different
governing bodies the Ico anti-money
laundering this check that check do I
need Indemnity and perfect all the
different checks and all the different
bodies that you're dealing with makes it
extremely overwhelming and quite
stressful and can make a lot of people
feel anxious before they even get into
property at all and the third potential
problem
is I've had quite a lot of students
because I've trained thousands of people
to get into deal sourcing and to get
into rentals and to get into property
and I've had quite a lot of people tell
me that when they're registered with the
property redress scheme it's not all
smooth sailing even though they'll take
money from deal sources even though
they'll take money from people doing
rent to rent when there's disputes they
always side against the person doing the
rental rent they always side against the
entrepreneur the deal sourcer now I
don't know if this is completely true or
not but what I will say is it's
interesting that the same people that
own the property redress scheme also own
landlord zone for example who are a
media outlet that continually bash rent
to rent they continually talk bad about
deal sourcing and rent to rent as a
general strategy so it's quite
concerning to me when I'm getting
hundreds of students complaining to me
not just about the process of being
compliant but also people saying that
they've had a really bad experience with
these governing bodies here's just one
example from last year from a student
that was left very very overwhelmed and
unhappy which made me just think
something needs to change tell us from
the beginning the brief summary of the
problem
know sometimes things don't go according
to plan but um what's been happening is
other like disputes because of
unrealistic expectations things not
working out in their view so if it goes
they go straight to the PRS to complain
without without any investigation or
anything like that to kind of help work
things out and what happens is with the
PRS is They Don't Really analyze the
information properly and so therefore
quite a long story short what this what
they're saying is is that I have to pay
a lot of money
right and if I don't then it's gonna
need to be me being removed from the PRS
and of course I won't be able to trade
because you have to be a member of the
Ombudsman and actually they have direct
links with the other Ombudsman so I
won't be able to join them either
so that's a situation is that the PRS
are not just really are really not
really analyzing the analyzing the
disputes properly in you know and
without despite the evidence being put
forward and that's the situation so
there's there's an issue here there's
quite a few issues so basically you have
to do as we say which she feels is
completely unfair and it's a lot of
money
or you're going to get birthmarked and
we're going to kick you out to PRS and
if you're not part of the PRS or the
Ombudsman then you can't trade can you
appeal the decision that's what I did I
appealed the decision it's like no you
can't literally you can't I they said no
my understanding is she's had an
independent advice and been advised from
an independent lawyer
that she doesn't owe the money I don't
know it really really I don't I don't
know it the PRS is I believe is
compromised
um because what they did and trying to
find it they leaked information on the
cases which I was in the process of
actually disputing and leaked out onto
social media
and property tribes I believe that
there's a each connection or
relationship with the the person who
runs property drives
and she's got a history of having
vendettas with people it's almost like
a corruption almost yeah because what it
is is that they take information
from someone who believes that they they
were wronged yeah and just run with it
without getting no
information on the other side and
without the accurate information
and that's what's happened and so now
it's like literally
I've been trolled basically
so what's the solution to this huge
problem what's the solution to this time
expense red tape to get into the
industry as deal sources and doing went
to rent and being a property
entrepreneur well I have been aware of
this problem for years and I am very
pleased to finally announce that I have
launched and set up my very own redress
scheme this is gonna absolutely
revolutionize the entire industry and it
is called the property investors
mediation service I've had to spend tens
of thousands of pounds in consultancy
fees to the top lawyers in the country
I'd like to speak to dozens of
consultants and Specialists and
regulations and authorities I've spoken
to the trading standards to get this
approved and it is now finally live the
property investors mediation service so
what does that mean for you if you're
wanting to start in property investment
and entrepreneur it when you register
for pens it will cover you for
everything your rent to rent your deal
sourcing your lease option agreements
your joint ventures you are covered in
pims you will also have the top most
up-to-date compliant contracts in place
in your hands without having to wait
months and months and spend thousands
and thousands of pounds what happens is
you receive your pims registration
number you can put the pins logo on your
website to show that you are covered by
pims and who is the chairman of pims me
if you have a dispute let's say you sell
a deal to an investor and then the
investor says oh I want my money back
and and there's a dispute there they
will then put in a complaint to pins
which saves you in legal costs which
saves you having to go to the small
claims Port it will go to pims pims will
firstly investigate the situation they
will then mediate between you and the
investor or if it's with a landlord or
if it's a joint venture they will
mediate and we have our top
investigators and mediators and lawyers
that work within pins and then finally
if we call up media and get a solution
hymns will adjudicate the situation and
they will say right this is what is fair
that will save you thousands of pounds
in court costs and lawyers fees and
consultation fees and give you a comfort
blanket of protection when you are a
member of pims meaning you can go out
there and start trading legally and
ethically without fear of being doing
something wrong or potentially getting
caught out by an investor but here's the
amazing thing when you are a member of
pims you are personally a member which
means that all of your companies if
you've got two or three different
companies or even five or six you can
have an earned limited amount of
companies which will be covered by pims
in one membership now of course if
you're a letting agent or if you're an
estate agent you will not be covered
you'll still have to be a member of the
PLS in TBR but if you're doing deal
sourcing or rank to rank some joint
ventures in the way that we teach you
are completely covered and the best
thing is sign up process literally takes
five minutes the pims website is live
the annual membership fee is 1995 and
that's inclusive of vat now if you're
just a bit interested in Deal sourcing
or you're just thinking I just like
watching YouTube videos you don't have
to become a member of pims but if you're
actually wanting to go out there and
start selling deals you want to start
taking on rent to rent and you want the
right contracts in hand you want to be
covered you want to be compliant and you
want to make sure you're operating
legally 1995 is actually a very very
small price to pay considering how much
it would cost you not only in money but
also in time and resources should you go
and register for all these other schemes
that now you don't have to do because we
have
thepims.co.uk and finally because I want
to make this just absolutely ridiculous
and I want you to succeed and I want you
to make a load of money as a deal source
that I'm doing rental rents and I know
that to do that you do need covering so
I'm going to say that for anyone that
registers now we're doing an April
special which is this not only we get
the bonus free training but you will
also get 50 off your first annual
membership fee of pins which I mean that
you can register right now for just 995
pounds have the contracts in your hand
be covered with our compliance and
mediation services you will not have to
worry about anything else to get started
as a deal sourcer and doing rent to
events right now if you register with
him so that's the huge announcement I'll
leave a link to the website below and I
look forward to helping you and seeing
you smash it as a property entrepreneur
in 2023.
thank you
[Music]